[Musik]
peru in südamerika ein land voller
naturschätze extrem abgelegen im
südosten perus liegt der mahnung
nationalpark er gilt als artenreichsten
gebiet der welt
das ist die super schatzkammer einlässt
muss man sagen der erde und das ist
natürlich auch ein starker antrieb
diesen park zu schützen
doch selbst dieses schwer zugängliche
gebiet ist und rot kann es gelingen manu
vor gefahren wie holzeinschlag und der
gier nach gold zu schützen
[Musik]
am morgen im südosten perus jenseits der
anden im amazonas tiefland
[Musik]
während der trockenzeit sammeln sich
jeden morgen aras und kleinere papageien
aus der ganzen umgebung an lehmigen
steilwänden
sie sind auf der suche nach salzen und
mineralien
denn daran herrscht mangel im regenwald
wo solche spektakel zu bewundern sind
ist die natur noch in ordnung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch bei ihrem schutz geht es um mehr
als schönheit und exotik die leistungen
intakter ökosysteme sind weltweit auch
für uns menschen redens wichtig
ein team der zoologischen gesellschaft
frankfurt ist unterwegs immer nur
national
die international tätige
naturschutzorganisation hat einen
ableger in peru als wissenschaftler hat
dr christoph schenker früher riesen oder
erforscht heute leitet er die
gesellschaft und ist seit rund 30 jahren
immer wieder vor ort
ich hoffe bei dieser reise feststellen
zu können in welchem zustand der park
ist wie es auch mit der bedrohung
aussieht im umfeld des parks und
natürlich interessiert mich aber wie ist
die situation der riesenotter hier in
den park
die männer reisen auf roten den straßen
gibt es nicht dabei müssen sie stets auf
umgestürzte bäume und andere hindernisse
achten unfälle sollte man hier draußen
unbedingt vermeiden
auch weil sich im wasser kaimane und
piranhas tummeln
[Musik]
hunderte von kilometern liegt das team
so auf den regenwald flüssen zurück
während der fahrt gibt es immer wieder
überraschende begegnungen ein tag hier
diese urzeitlich anmutenden kreaturen
werden hier nur sehr selten gesehen
südamerika 3 ich am ursprünglichen
naturräumen
besonders vielfältig ist peru in dessen
südosten der manu national park liegt
erstreckt sich von den östlichen
auslaufende an bis ins tiefland des
amazonas über eine höhendifferenz von
rund 4.000 metern und ist gut 17.000
quadratkilometer groß im herzen des
gebietes fliesst der namensgebende manu
fluss die für verschiedene lebensräume
ist einer der gründe für die enorme
artenvielfalt perus der manu national
park beherbergt die größte vielfalt an
tier und pflanzenarten die der
wissenschaft bekannt ist
bei den vögeln wird das besonders
deutlich
1030 verschiedene arten leben den nano
rund zehn prozent aller vogelarten der
erde 228 verschiedene säugetiere bogen
nachgewiesen etwa vier prozent aller
säugetierarten
hinzu kommen zahlreiche wirbellose
amphibien und reptilien
[Musik]
auf einem hektar regenwald finden sich
hier mehr als 200 verschiedene baumarten
und andere pflanzen von denen einige
erstaunliche ausmaße erreichen können
januar sind die größten jäger im wald
während riesigen kaimane die gewässer
beherrschen sie jagen unter anderem
wasserschweine die größten nagetiere der
welt
[Musik]
doch selbst dieses paradies ist in
gefragt
[Musik]
in der nähe wird regenwald gerodet legal
und illegal für straßenbauprojekte oder
holzgewinnung
[Musik]
mit dem wald verschwindet auch die
artenvielfalt
seit jahrzehnten versuchen ranger der
peruanischen behörden am gemeinsam mit
internationalen naturschützern diesen
verlust aufzuhalten
im manu national tag ist ihnen das
bisher weitgehend gelungen doch anderswo
machen wirtschaftliche interessen ihrer
anstrengungen oft zunichte
wenn der wald verschwunden ist folgen
straßen die wiederum das einfallstor für
weitere zerstörung sind die
rodungsfläche dienen später als
viehweiden für die fleischproduktion die
einstige artenvielfalt ist ihr nur noch
eine blasse erinnerung
[Musik]
eine bedrohung die sich erst auf den
zweiten blick erschließt ist der anbau
des koka strauches seine heimat sind die
ost hänge der anden wo er bis heute
traditionell angepflanzt wird
einheimische schätzen tee aus
kokablättern wegen seiner anregenden
wirkung doch aus der ferne zu lässt sich
auch kokain hier stellen
der legale oder illegale anbau zu
unterscheiden in peru ist gar nicht so
einfach weil eigentlich ist ja gar nicht
mal verboten
koka pflanzen anzubauen was allerdings
überall verboten ist aus diesen pflanzen
aus den blättern der koka pflanze das
alkaloid herauszulösen und daraus kocher
hin zu produzieren das sind natürlich
auch hohe hektarerträge uns dann ganz
schwer die bauern von eigentlich einer
anderen oder besseren nutzung oder
andere anderen pflanze zu überzeugen
sie sieht harmlos aus doch die pflanze
ist der grund für eine hohe kriminalität
und geht davon aus dass ungefähr 20
tonnen kokain in deutschland importiert
werden ein kilo kokain wird in
deutschland verfasst für 80.000 euro
verkauft dafür sterben menschen die
drogenmafia gc skrupellos vor und ist
gut organisiert
schließlich ist es nicht leicht
tonnenweise kokain außer landes zu
schaffen
also wir sehen tatsächlich verstärkt
flugzeugbewegungen hier in der region
und das deutet eher darauf hin dass es
im zusammenhang steht mit den kartellen
mit der coca mafia
dafür werden auch illegal pisten
angelegt und auch da sucht man natürlich
die abgeschiedenheit und deswegen sind
schutzgebiete die eben großen und
abgelegen sind immer besonders gefährdet
in der manuel region liegt eine der
illegalen landebahnen
dort hat die polizei eines der chor hier
flugzeuge gesprengt eine gefährliche
aktion denn die drogenbanden sind
äußerst gewaltbereit bisher konnten die
behörden das kartell nicht aufhalten
es gibt neue illegale anbauflächen neue
pisten und neue flugzeuge berufs
bedeutung im geschäft wächst
früher war kolumbien führen heute gilt
er als einer der größten lieferanten für
kokain für die welt vor allem natürlich
für die westliche welt und deswegen ist
es auch hat es sehr sehr große ausmaße
hier im regenwald und hat auch wirklich
starke einflüsse auf die zerstörung des
regenwaldes
bisher findet die kokain produktion vor
allem benachbart zum nationalpark stadt
das herz des gebietes ist wild und kaum
zugänglich dort leben sogar noch
ursprüngliche indigene völker mit einem
kontroll posten was das
kulturministerium darüber dass ihnen
möglichst nichts geschieht
christof schenck und sein peruanischer
kollege oscar monika chacón nutzen die
gelegenheit um sich ein bild zu machen
sie treffen einen mitarbeiter des
ministeriums der erklärt dass die
indigenen in unregelmäßigen abständen am
gegenüber liegenden ufer scheiden
ostafrika chacón hatte jedoch schon eine
begegnung mit ihm kam aus einem anderen
teil des nationalparks und sahen dort
plötzlich eine gruppe von
unkontaktierten inzwischen haben fast
alle indigenen völker der erde kontakt
zur westlichen zivilisation südamerika
ist der letzte kontinent auf dem noch
unkontaktierte indigene leben
anfangs waren sie sehr neugierig aber
einige von ihnen wirken auch aggressiv
denn sie hielten steine in den händen
der hand kurz darauf nach ein paar
minuten begannen sie sich zu unterhalten
aber wir konnten ihre sprache nicht
verstehen
tatsächlich prallen hier welten
aufeinander die mitarbeiter des
ministeriums beobachten nur und lassen
die indigenen selbst entscheiden ob sie
kontakt zur außenwelt suchen
[Musik]
aus unserer sicht sollen sie einfach
selbst bestimmt leben ganz wie sie
wollen
wir respektieren das und sorgen dafür
dass niemand versucht kontakt zu ihm
aufzunehmen
wir versuchen schlechte einflüsse von
ihr fernzuhalten
sie sollen ihre kultur erhalten können
und wir respektieren ihre territorialen
ansprüche dass menschen hier noch ein
sehr ursprüngliches leben führen können
ist ein weiteres gütesiegel für das
gebiet wird immer wieder gesagt leben
wie steinzeitmenschen das hat sich aber
sehr negativ eigentlich an tatsächlich
ist es so dass sie kein metall kennen
oder kein metall herstellen vielleicht
haben sie mal irgendwo mit macheten oder
eine axt erbeuten können aber
grundsätzlich kennen sie nicht ich würde
das eher als etwas außergewöhnlich
positiv sehen es ist nämlich menschen
die ein integraler bestandteil des
ökosystems regenwald sind und eigentlich
in der modernen welt sind wir auf dem
weg gegangen wo wir eigentlich
großflächig über den planeten eigentlich
zerstörung bringen und das ist hier ein
sehr großer unterschied
[Musik]
zusammen mit seinem team ist christoph
schenk auf der suche nach riesenotter
sie sind typisch für das gebiet leben
aber nicht an manu fluss selbst sondern
vor allem in alt arm um dort mobil zu
sein brauchen die männer ein tragbares
bot vor ihnen liegt üppiger regenwald
mehr als 50 meter hoch sind einige der
urwaldriesen am wegesrand
[Musik]
vogelspinnen lauern im unterholz auf
beute
[Musik]
weiter oben sind kapuzineraffen
unterwegs sie sind stets neugierig
[Musik]
altarme sind ehemalige flussschleife die
inzwischen vom hauptstrom abgetrennt
sind ein idealer lebensraum für die otto
vor rund 30 jahren konnte christof
schenck die riesenotter je erstmals
beobachten für 60 sekunden
diese begegnung hat sein ganzes leben
verändert der zoologe begann die tiere
wissenschaftlich zu untersuchen und hat
seine doktorarbeit über sie verfasst
natürlich interessiert ihn wie es ihnen
jetzt geht
wir finden riesen oder nur noch in den
besten regenwälder amazoniens in den
ursprünglichsten lebensräumen riesen
oder leben ja von den fischen entlang
der flüsse und das ist genau der ort wo
auch der stärkste menschliche einfluss
stattfindet also von überfischung
ackerbau viehzucht illegaler goldwäscher
reihe holzeinschlag alles das empfindet
entlang der flüsse stadt das heißt wenn
wir irgendwo riesen oder finden
dann wissen wir eigentlich sofort also
dass es wirklich noch ein sehr sehr
gutes gebiet die abgelegene wildnis des
manu national parks stellt für sie ein
wichtiges rückzugsgebiet dar
dennoch gehören sie zu den seltensten
raubtieren der welt als die ersten orte
auftauchen bleiben sie zunächst auf
abstand sein wissen über die tiere
musste sich christoph schenk während
seiner dreijährigen feldforschung schwer
arbeiten und hat schon immer erstaunt
warum man eigentlich über die
riesenotter so wenig weiß immerhin cindy
tagaktiv das sind gruppen leben und aber
als wir dann hier waren dabei uns schon
klar warum das so ist es einfach
unglaublich hat hier dauerhaft zu leben
und die tiere zu beobachten vor allem in
der regenzeit ist das enorm
entbehrungsreich sind sehr viele
moskitos man ist eigentlich immer nass
pilze wachsen in den linsen der kameras
und auf der haut also schon harter job
feindlicher den orden zu folgen
tagoes an doch sind die biologen wieder
mit ihrem boot unterwegs
ein guter zeitpunkt denn während der
nacht haben die otter geruht und nicht
gefressen
entsprechend hungrig sind sie am
nächsten morgen und brechen zur jagd auf
[Musik]
christoph schenk hat das monitoring der
tiere hier begonnen
inzwischen wird es vom peruanischen
biologen weitergeführt riesenotter haben
eine besondere zeichnung anhalts die
sogenannten kehl flecke daran lässt sich
jedes tier individuell erkennen
der abgleich mit einem datenblatt verrät
ob es bereits bekannt ist so lassen sich
viele wertvolle erkenntnisse gewinnen
wir konnten von einer ganzen reihe von
tieren über diese individuelle kell
fleck mustererkennung wirklich den
lebensweg verfolgen wir konnten wirklich
miterleben wie sie herangewachsen sind
wie sie dann als junge tiere die gruppe
verlassen haben einen neuen alten
gefunden haben und dort eine neue
familien gruppe gegründet haben und
schließlich selber junge hatten also das
wirklich zu verfolgen ist einfach schon
kannst all das ist schon irgendwie so
der traum von dem feld biologen
riesenotter können zwei meter lang
werden und sind die größten aller orte
um ihren energiebedarf zu decken
benötigen sie täglich etwa vier kilo
fisch eine durchschnittliche
familiengruppe braucht schon rund 30
kilo fisch und das jeden tag die tiere
können also nur in sehr produktiven
lebensräumen existieren
früher wurden die otter wegen ihrer
dichten pelzes fast bis zur ausrottung
gejagt vielleicht 5000 haben bis heute
überlebt
[ __ ] kaimane kommen im selben
lebensraum vorgehen den selbstbewussten
riesen ort dann aber meist aus dem weg
nicht weit entfernt durch streiten noch
weiter jäger den ball
[Applaus]
matschie ging ja indianer bis heute
jagen sie hier mit traditionellen
methoden keine leichte aufgabe
aus sicht der einheimischen hat das
leben im wald durchaus vorteile in der
stadt muss man für alles bezahlen
aber hier bei uns sein wie nichts denn
was wir zum essen brauchen liefert der
wald oder wie bonus auf unseren feldern
an wenn sie kein jagddruck haben sammeln
sie pflanzen wie die partygänger leben
an der schwelle zwischen zwei welten
längst nutzen sie machten und andere
werkzeuge der kern ihrer
dorfgemeinschaft ist die familie de
grâce kinder oft schon als teenager
gründen sechs kinder haben
ben und seine frau bereits mehrere
generationen leben unter einem dach
während ruben aus holz waffen für die
jagd er stellt fertigt seine frau
natalia ketten und armbänder aus
fernsten sorgen
mit dem selbst hergestellten schmuck
betreiben sie einen bescheidenen handel
obwohl sich bisher nur wenige reisende
in diesen abgelegenen teil der welt
vorwagen förderprogramme bringen
zusätzliche einnahmen
mit dem geld was sie jetzt bekommen
können sie einerseits natürlich güter
bekommen kaufen die sie vorher nicht
bekommen konnten mit dem schweren
außenbordmotor oder andere andere dinge
die sie gerne hätten
aber vor allem ist es so vorher war ja
so dass alle eine zugang zu allem hatten
nämlich den ressourcen des regenwaldes
und jetzt plötzlich ist es so dass man
wirklich wert der akkumulieren kann also
eine völlig veränderte gesellschaft auch
das leben von natalia und ihrer familie
hat sich bereits stark verändert sie
jagen affen und sammeln müsse im wald
gleichzeitig betreiben sie mit anderen
familien eine kleine leute im dschungel
natalia kümmert sich um die zimmer
verdienstmöglichkeiten gibt es hier
draußen nur wenige für meine kinder
wünsche ich mir dass sie viel lernen und
mehr erreichen als ich habe ja keinen
richtigen beruf ihnen soll es mal besser
gehen als mehr
das ist eine rasante entwicklung für die
andere kulturen jahrhunderte zeit hatten
doch hier verläuft der wechsel von einem
traditionellen zu einem modernen leben
mitunter in einer generation für
steigende bedürfnisse muss aber auch der
wald stärker genutzt werden
die indianer und die indigenen völker
haben schon immer hier gelebt sogar
bevor es den park eigentlich gegeben hat
nichtsdestotrotz ist der park
eingerichtet worden von der nation peru
und hat eigentlich auch eine welt
bedeutung und diese zwei konflikte muss
man jetzt übereinander bringen und dass
es ganz schwierig und da wird es keine
ideale lösung geben
also was sicher ganz wichtig ist die
menschen langsam in die moderne welt zu
führen und eigentlich muss man sagen die
große zukunft kann nur außerhalb des
parks liegen
ein gutes stück flussabwärts schließt
der mann am fluss in den madre de dios
[Musik]
dort liegt der kleine ort wo kam am mit
eigenem internat das von der
zoologischen gesellschaft frankfurt
betrieben wird
die meisten indigenen schüler die aus
der umgebung stammen könnten nicht an
einem tag kommen und gehen dafür sind
die wege zu weit und zu beschwerlich
durch mehr bildungen sollen die kinder
bessere persönliche perspektiven
erhalten
tatsächlich gab es bislang keine
schwangerschaften unter den teenagern
der indianermädchen aber so herzlich die
atmosphäre auch sein mag hier draußen
hat man trotz guter ausbildung nur
begrenzte möglichkeiten
eine tätigkeit jedoch lockt durch sehr
lukrative gewinne die suche nach gold
das edelmetall kommt hier im sediment
der flüsse vor
[Musik]
hunderte solcher apparaturen stehen in
den umliegenden flüssen am madre de dios
oder am tambor katar eine dieselpumpe
saugt das sediment auf ein großes sieht
bei der förderung wird die umwelt extrem
belastet deswegen ist diese form der
goldsucher eigentlich illegal grobe
steine werden aussortiert goldpartikel
bleiben in einer mathe mit feinen poren
hängen obwohl die goldsucher verboten
ist machen tausende glücksritter hier
nichts anderes leider gibt es hier in
der region nicht viel arbeit und wir
müssen gewisse risiken eingehen
bisher wurde das goldwaschen noch nicht
legalisiert daher sitzen wird zwischen
den stühlen
es gibt für uns keinen anderen weg zu
arbeiten um den gold staub zu binden
nutzen manuell und seine kollegen
quecksilber ein hochgiftiges
schwermetall das bei zimmertemperatur
flüssig ist
von der illegalen praxis profitieren
nicht nur die goldwäscher am fluss
sondern auch ihre hintermänner
lokale politiker drücken gern ein auge
zu wenn es sich für sie lohnt
durch mehrmaliges umfüllen maschen und
auspressen wird das metallische gemisch
verdichtet der überschuss landet in den
flüssen und wird von ihnen oft über
tausende kilometer transportiert eine
vergiftung mit quecksilber kann bei
menschen unter anderem zu
nervenschädigungen führen bei
ungeborenen auch zum schwersten
behinderungen
ganze landstriche werden vergiftet
am ende bleibt ein kleines stück metall
durch das quecksilber noch ohne goldene
firmung so eine giftige geschichte sieht
man nicht an
hier ist nichts versorgt das ist eine
lüge
wie viele menschen sind an quecksilber
gestorben
dafür gibt es gar keine beweise sie
sagen alles sei er vergiftet aber das
stimmt nicht wechselbar ist schwer
und wenn es ins wasser gelangt singt es
ist unmöglich dass fische oder andere
lebewesen dadurch kontaminiert werden
doch quecksilber ist türkisch und
vergiftet sehr langsam
der klumpen wird erhitzt um gold und
schwermetall voneinander zu trennen
dabei gelangen toxische substanzen in
die atmosphäre
die mit dem nächsten regen weiter
verteilt werden wenn das quecksilber
verdampft ist lässt sich erstmals die
farbe des gold stücks erkennen einmal
eingeschmolzen das passiert natürlich
immer sofort vor ort kann man nicht mehr
unterscheiden woher dieses gold gewonnen
wurde also ist es aus einer illegalen
mine gewonnen wurden oder ist es illegal
zum beispiel aus den sedimenten der
flüssige waschen worden
[Musik]
in der nahen goldgräberstadt puerto
maldonado in der region madre de dios
kommt das gold in den handel
die händler prüfen ob ihnen noch
wirklich eines gold angeboten wird sie
machen eine feuerprobe denn für die
rechte von quecksilber möchten sie nicht
zahlen
direkt hier ein matthäus wird schon
legales und illegales gold miteinander
vermischt und hier gibt es direkte
transportwege nach europa entscheiden
sind nämlich die abnehmer dann in der
westlichen welt oder jetzt auch
zunehmend in der asiatischen welt und
sie haben eine große verantwortung und
niemand der heute in gold investiert
weiß eigentlich oder macht sich
überhaupt gedanken darüber unter welchen
unglaublichen umweltzerstörung die ihr
gold gewonnen wird und was das
eigentlich auch langfristig für einen
leid und verderben in die menschen
trifft
[Musik]
das ausmaß der zerstörung ist gigantisch
das wasser ist verseucht die
kontaminierten flächen unbewohnbar die
trans so ca nica eine landstraße die vom
atlantik zum pazifik quer durch
südamerika führt machte die erschließung
erst möglich
[Musik]
rund 60.000 menschen arbeiten im
südosten perus als illegale goldsucher
ein ende des booms ist nicht in sicht
das tragische an dieser goldsucher ist
dass man natürlich verstehen kann dass
die einzelne familie unbedingt gerne ein
gutes eine gute einnahmequelle hat das
ist durchaus verständlich aber die
zerstörung ist natürlich ganz
großflächig und vor allem ganz ganz
langwierig und bezahlen tun die die
nämlich keine stimme haben weisst du
noch nicht mal geboren sind weil sie die
in die in eine welt hinein wachsen um
die großflächig die umwelt wie wir sie
heute kennen eigentlich zerstört wurde
die regenwälder des manu national parks
liegen im amazonas tiefland und sind
teil des größten tropischen regenwaldes
der erde
er hat nicht nur regionale sondern
globale bedeutung für das klima ein
ausfall wäre unkalkulierbar
[Musik]
das aussterben von bedrohten tierarten
wie riesenotter mag uns in europa nicht
betreffen
aber es sind anzeichen dafür dass die
systeme nicht mehr funktionieren systeme
die als globales netz arbeiten und auf
deren leistungen auch wir angewiesen
sind für luft zum atmen
für gesunde nahrungsmittel für sauberes
wasser
es geht um den erhalt unserer eigenen
lebensgrundlagen
[Musik]